two years ago colin kaepernick to the me
during the national anthem to spotlight
social injustice as that silent protest
spread it caused an uproar but a group
of NFL players has been quietly working
to enact change recently I spoke with
Super Bowl champions Chris Long and
Malcolm Jenkins who believe the
controversy has drowned out the real
work that's being done off the field the
NFL has suspended its controversial new
policy that policy required players to
stand the league will now negotiate with
the Players Union over a new policy what
Colin did was find out a way to bring up
the conversation and force a
conversation really it's up to us to
stay focused to make sure that the
issues and topics they're at the
forefront that is would this all started
from and that's what we'll continue to
fight about for Philadelphia Eagles
safety Malcolm Jenkins this is what the
fight is all about the greatest impact
is to work together use our platform on
the first Sunday of the NFL season
jenkins called a listen and learn
session in philadelphia a meeting with
business community and government
leaders on the agenda bail reform and
jobs there are so many people in our
networks that can start to work on their
issues he's asking everyone at the table
for help this is not the sexy story that
everybody wants to see and it's not a
headline grabber but these meetings and
the things that you are doing in the
community this is the change that you
are trying to enact we're learning the
ins and out of our justice system and
changing minds as we go what has been
the most surprising thing that you've
learned so far that is really not that
tough of a change when you look at
politics it really comes down to
priority we've talked to lawmakers all
over the place that would agree that a
lot of these reforms need a change would
agree that things are unfair or a little
unjust but if voters aren't clamoring
about it
then it's not high enough on a priority
to change things
I am Doug Baldwin and I am here again as
a concerned citizen two years ago an
alliance of NFL players formed to take
the sideline protests to state capitals
across the country this past offseason
the group now officially known as the
players coalition successfully lobbied
for criminal justice reform bills in
three states in April
Massachusetts raised the juvenile
detention age from seven to twelve in
May the Louisiana State Senate passed a
law restoring voting rights to people
convicted of a felony who've been on
probation or parole for five years and
in June players successfully lobbied
Pennsylvania lawmakers in Harrisburg to
pass the clean slate Act which seals the
records of people with misdemeanors
after ten years along with those
arrested but not convicted of a crime
you know the three pieces of legislation
this is a real substantive stuff I mean
in three different markets all around
the u.s. Chris long is one of Jenkins
teammates working alongside him for
change including donating his base
salary from last season to charity I'll
always remember this because I was just
getting in the coalition and I was after
a Monday night game we got on a train at
you know 7:00 in the morning got a
Harrisburg man I pulled one of the
representatives is how it I was like
does this really help I was like do you
guys really care what we say and the
dudes like absolutely he's like y'all
need to come back more often you'd be
surprised I know it's not right that
people just listen to football players
but people are listening to football
players and when you guys come here
there's a buzz and to hear that
reinforcement was like okay well we can
really affect change and once we were
able to lend our platform our voices and
be able to sit down with legislators and
made a big difference and so that's why
we laugh when people say stick there
sports because we see firsthand how much
impact we can have by not sticking to
sports but if we stuck to sports I think
the world would be a lot more boring and
a lot less productive are you upset with
the White House and the president for
canceling the trip
but not everyone has been listening what
are we listening to compelling Malcolm
Jenkins to hold posters in front of his
locker this summer highlighting the
issues like the disproportionate number
of African Americans shot by police or
the half million people in jail because
they can't afford to post bail and it
just has a message that we have to stay
on topic because we're purposely
choosing to overlook what it is that
players have been even fighting for
because we've been very articulate and
very patient and consistent with police
brutality systemic racism education
housing and yet will continuously hear
this dialogue players don't know what
they're doing or they're not organized
or they're anti-military disrespecting
well yeah it's nonsense and those
statistics and those things that are on
those poster cards people don't want to
hear about it that literally left people
no choice but to air that when we do
talk we will rattle off those same
statistics but the only thing that ends
up in the article is my opinions on the
President or the NFL or the anthem so in
order to get the words that we want out
there we have to be creative in a way
that we control that message we had
great to focus on the social justice
issue the NFL is lending its backing to
the players coalition with a social
justice partnership earlier this month
Commissioner Roger Goodell attended a
listen and learn session in New Orleans
and the league has pledged eighty nine
million dollars in support what does
that money mean to you it's money that
we can now give to the people who are
doing his work there are grassroots
organizations that need help and need
support when the NFL came to us we just
said we want your support and here's how
you can support us but not only with the
money because you can cut a check for
our ever much you want we also want
their platform we want the voice and the
same way that they highlight issues like
breast cancer for an entire month or
soluta service all of these other
initiatives that we've seen them promote
and put their weight behind seventy
percent of people in jail have never
been convicted of a crime do you think
that you're risking your careers by
being a part of a player's coalition by
taking stands I'm pretty old so
you know it's my 10th year this is your
11th so we're on the back end of our
careers but what we're trying to create
years from now players that come into
the league where the rookies don't have
to worry about oh if I get politically
active in my community that is somehow
affects my job no longer is that
vilified but that's almost the standard
is all that you're doing good for the
game of football
no I'm not concerned yeah I mean we
talked about it football provides our
livelihood for not only us but the other
2,000 players that are in the league and
those to come and those who came before
us so we never want to do anything
that's gonna damage the game but at the
end of the day the lives of everyday
Americans are more important than my
ability to make a living which even if
it was damaged a little bit would still
be a great living so when you compared
it to I think for me that's a simple
choice
first of all great story don't thank
great story and the optics of those two
players sitting side-by-side working
together right and Malcolm like leading
the charge and Chris right behind yeah
and you and I were talking about this
off-camera the idea that it is black and
white these are issues that may affect
more people that are black but they
realize that you need support from
everyone Malcolm said this voting voting
power does not come from the black
community we need white players standing
with us and saying this is an American
problem not just a black and they're not
just doing this at their lockers they're
doing it in the communities where the
real hard work is to have these
conversations they're going to the
lawmakers it makes a difference and they
are taking the time when they should be
or possibly would have been doing other
stuff there they're making a difference
either of them with those signs yeah ah
those are women across the country with
the players kind of believable